we have the opportunity as conservatives
to
be the party of the working class to be
the party of the ordinary citizen
to be the party not of the
global cosmopolitan
laptop class elite
who don't really mind lockdowns because
lockdowns don't really affect them and
who don't really have any respect for
national borders and who don't really
have any respect for national traditions
right we're that's the democrats that's
the left that's not us
we can be the
party of the traditional way of life and
good old common sense and prudence if we
seize that opportunity the libs are
making it very easy for us
gavin newsom
gavin newsom
governor of california just showed up to
the la rams game
in la
la which has an indoor mask mandate
for
big events
he goes to the game and what happens
he takes a photo with magic johnson
neither of whom are wearing masks there
are other photos of gavin newsom from
this event he's sitting he's chatting
he's having a good time he's not wearing
his mask
he gets this photo with magic johnson
which is even crazier because magic
johnson you will know
has
aids he's had aids for decades he is
immuno he is as immunocompromised as
they get and yet magic johnson's not
cowering in fear with the mask gavin
newsom's not cowering in fear with the
mask this photo was taken other photos
were taken gavin newsom tried to explain
it away
i was very judicious yesterday
very judicious and you'll see the photo
that i did take
where
magic was kind enough generous enough to
ask me for a photograph and in my left
hand's the mask and i took a photo
rest the time i wore it
as we all should um
not when i had a glass of water or
anything and uh encourage everybody else
to do so and uh
that's it
and that's it it's just look we just
took this photo okay and it was uh
we just we just and and it's fine it's
not a big deal except there are other
videos there are videos of them walking
up hugging it's not just that briefly
you take the mask down in between sips
in between bites take a quick photo no
they weren't wearing their masks
and magic i should say magic johnson has
hiv he doesn't have full blown aids he
has he has hiv
pretty immunocompromised
okay it's quite immunocompromised
that's the word that was the word of
2020. immunocompromised no one had ever
used that word before now everybody uses
that word
except the the most immunocompromised
people
not not not so worried about it what's
that about
i am beginning to think
that what most protects people
from covid19
is not
masks again i'm not making a medical
claim about masks or vaccines or
whatever please youtube don't please
youtube don't take me down okay
i'm just saying what most protects
people from covid19 it's not the masks
and it's not the vaccines
i think what it is is um
money and power
because there's this just an observation
i've made
really rich
really powerful people
they don't follow any of the public
health measures that they encourage
other people to follow
i'm thinking of people like the mayor of
san francisco i'm thinking of people
like the mayor of new york i'm thinking
of people like joe biden i'm thinking
people like dr fauci i'm thinking of
all of these people
they don't but they're the one thing
they have in common is they're really
rich and they're really powerful
and they want you to live according to a
set of rules that they themselves
will not follow
i guess we all just need to become
really rich and powerful and then we
won't catch covet either
or maybe there's something else going on
maybe
a lot of this covid regime that we're
living under
is not so much about the virus and it's
not so much about the health and the
cough and the chills
maybe it's a little bit more about
reshaping the political order with the
historic inflation that we're all
dealing with today it's more important
than ever to save some money you ever
wonder how to strike the best deals and
save up to i don't know ninety percent
nine zero on brand new items without
even needing to leave your home look no
further than dealdash one of the leading
auction sites in the united states with
over a decade in business whether you
are in the market for a basic kitchen
appliance or a luxury upgrade to your
old tv dealdash will allow you to get
the best deals on whatever you're
looking for they've got hundreds of
auctions daily on brand new items from
tvs and laptops to tools and kitchenware
even cars with guaranteed free shipping
ipads have sold for
and sixty cents brand new cars have sold
for less than one thousand dollars all
auctions start at zero dollars you have
a 90 day money back guarantee on your
first bid pack purchase you can use deal
dash both online deal dash dot com as
well as through ios and android apps the
game mechanics are simple all auctions
start at zero bucks each bid raises the
final auction price by one cent and
resets the clock to 10 seconds after the
10 seconds run out the final bidder wins
and can claim the auction win by paying
the final price don't be made victim to
today's inflation get all the new
products that you desire without price
hikes at deal dash today use promo code
knowles kwles for an additional 100 free
bids when making your first bid pack
purchase and start bidding
heyo thanks for checking out that clip
that's cool man nice to be with you if
you want more clips
ring the bell subscribe leave a five
star review on apple podcast spot if i
stitch your google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts get it here at
youtube get it at the daily wire get it
on your audio podcast app get it
anywhere you can
to stave off the sensors we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you